a reboot boys is when Hollywood wants to
make a lot of money without the hassle
of creating a new movie so they take an
old movie and change just enough to make
you pay for the same [ __ ] all over again
most greedy [ __ ] in all oh it's
insidious they take a flick you loved as
a kid nad youth and diversity to it for
example name the movie where a robot has
secret plans that could help the good
guys beat the bad guys in their leader
and a black mask by blowing up a giant
Raygun in space Star Wars no the force
awakens see now that's what you call a
reboot
none thought that was a sequel Hollywood
doesn't make sequels anymore [ __ ] they
never makes Squeakquel Zeo Studios have
given up on new ideas entirely in favor
of building multi movie universes that
breed brand loyal customers from cradle
to grave so if you like Harry Potter
cash-in I guess you're getting 10
[ __ ] more you like The Fast and
Furious flicks we're gonna drive the
franchise into the ground [ __ ] oh you
want another Marvel movie here we go
hey man those marble movies are a
triumph of cinema I live on those Marvel
movies I live for those Marvel movies i
watch those Marvel movies more than I
watch porn hub and I come twice as are
doing it
you